we know that until it's eradicated,
polio remains a very real threat,
especially to children in the poorest communities of the world.
It can reemerge in some of the most remote and dangerous places,
and from there, it can spread.
And so this is my new Ironman:
to end polio.
And I am reminded every day,
when I look at my two-and-a-half-year-old daughter Maya.
She is able to climb a ladder in the park,
push her scooter or kick a ball across the grass.
Almost everything that I see her do at her age
reminds me of what I could not do at that age.
And when she was two months old,
I took her to get her first polio vaccine.
And when the doctor came in the room to prepare the shot,
I asked him if I could take a picture to document the moment.
When we left the room,
I could feel my eyes welling up with tears.
I cried the entire way home.
It was in that moment that I realized
that my daughter's life would be very different from mine.
She will never be faced with the crippling disability of polio,
because a vaccine was available, and I chose to get her immunized.
She can do anything she wants,
as can each of you.
(Laughter)
Now I'd like to leave you all with one question:
what is your Ironman?
Thank you.
(Applause)